i think you fell in love with yourself
so what there's a lot about me to love
selena gomez is bringing back alex russo
ah there it is a little piece of good
darn it the 29 year old actress is
paying homage to her wizards of waverly
place character in her latest tock and
get this she's also teasing new music
i think you fell in love with yourself
so what there's a lot about me to love
i feel pretty
just
let's break this down starting off the
top that audio you heard was selena lip
dubbing this line from her classic
disney channel sitcom i think you fell
in love with yourself
so what there's a lot about me to love
then the clip transitions into an
unreleased song i feel pretty
so pretty
i feel pretty
if that sample sounds familiar it's
because it is selena's tune features the
song i feel pretty from the broadway
musical and 1961 film west side story i
feel pretty
oh so pretty
i feel pretty and witty and gay
but not only is selena teasing new music
she's also showing off a new hairdo i'm
just about to go hit rock bottom so i
was wondering if anyone needs anything
while i'm there the singer recently
debuted a blunt bob look giving off
total alex russo vibes now selena is no
stranger to surprising her fans on tick
tock the rare beauty founder and her
little sis gracie have been making a lot
of videos lately including this full
house reenactment in july i'm older i'm
younger i'm taller i'm stronger i'm
smarter i'm
not falling for that that video has
36.4 million views and counting oh my
goodness yeah it's amazing selena has
also gotten her only murders in the
building co-stars steve martin and
martin short to join in on her tick tock
fun okay so what are we just talking
about we're the ogs
back in august e.t spoke with the trio
about filming the series and how selena
kept them hip on all things pop culture
i'm officially the third amiga amiga i
should say yeah you know she tells steve
lyrics to thongs
songs
wait selena did you explain [ __ ] to them
i certainly why can't you say w.a.p
because that's not what they say that's
not what the kids that's like calling
the usa usa
[Laughter]
thank you for this service selena what
did you guys think when you learned the
meaning of wap well well i you know i i
i've known it for years that was like
[Music]